andy it's good to have you here with us
and i just want to kind of catch up with
you real quick i know the last couple
years has been quarantined life's been
weird for everyone yeah but you are a
father of some very young children how
are you holding up the minute my
daughter came home from the hospital and
we were we were home
that first night and i was like wow this
too feels really like a family and i was
like wow this feels so good like this is
my family this is what i was meant to be
and so
i love i'm just i'm so looking forward
to what's to come but it's
it's really hard how do you date
well you know what dating is another
story because
you know i haven't
there are two kinds of people
people that you want to date
and people that people that you want to
bang okay thank you thank you
you open the door for me on this and i
wasn't going to go there you open the
door okay so the answer is the dating
thing
that you know i i have had some dates
but
it's gotten in my mind more
kind of emotionally chaotic because in
my mind you know there was there was a
guy that i had been dating and i said to
him at one point you there's kind of a
third thing in the room here as we're
dating and he said i know he said well
what do you think that is i said it's
that i have a family and he said oh no i
view that third thing is that you're
famous
and i'm like wow i don't even think
about that i'm like we've been out 15
times how is being famous affected
any of the times we've been out like
it's been fine
so i thought that was interesting but
that's taking up noise in my head
the dating thing because i'm like oh my
god i'm not only dating someone
but
i'm dating someone obviously there's
going to be a point where i'm like i
want you to meet my kids you said you
you went on 15 dates with this guy right
15 dates is a long time i imagine 15
days do you talk about a few months yeah
never met the kids
no he did and how is that how do you
decide when you when when it's like the
right time you know what actually this
is someone who had
met my son
um we were i was on a vacation with my
son and so and and i had met this guy
when i was on vacation
um and so he actually had met him but
okay the answer is it just i just vibed
it out when the time felt right
you